what's going on guys welcome to another
video in the Python charting stocks and
doing some mathematics tutorial series
this video we're gonna be talking about
standard deviation what is it and how do
we calculate it in Python and then how
do we actually chart it up standard
deviation is just simply a measure of
how like variable a data set is around
its mean or average and just like our
moving averages either simple or
exponential it's usable in like a bunch
of fields it's not just simply in
finance so to calculate standard
deviation what you're going to need to
do is step 1 find the average of your
data set then you're going to want to
find the variance of that data set and
so to do that you're going to need to
calculate the difference of each
basically number from its mean and then
you square that answer sep 3 you're
gonna add up each numbers variance and
then divide it by the total number of
numbers that you're considering -1 so
usually you'll see this as n minus 1
finally just square root number 3 and
you'll have your answer of standard
deviation now let's consider doing this
with in Python
I'm going to go ahead and do that in
this same video normally I would do in
the next video but it's simple enough to
do within Python that I can just stuff
it into this video and then the next
video we'll work on you know getting it
charted okay so once you could open a
blank Python script let's work on
converting some data so first we're
going to import numpy as NP then we're
gonna go ahead and define our little
list here so let's say we make a list
you know x equals and we'll just throw
some numbers into here that's good
enough now what we want to do is convert
this to an umpire array so we can just
say numpy dot array and now we have
converted that then we want to just say
standard nev equals x dot STD which is
the way to convert to a standard
deviation basically and then actually we
leave the parameters and
t-there now normally you could specify
an axes on there and do all sorts of
crazy stuff but we'll leave that for a
later video now we just want to print
standard B save that go ahead and run it
and you'll get your answer as in our
case it's two point four five four so
each thing is within two point five four
points of the average here so that's how
to calculate standard deviation the next
video we will be plotting it we had to
skip over a little lot as you know I'm
going in alphabetical order of all these
stock indicators but the next one was
Bollinger Bands and it just so happens
that Bollinger Bands actually use
standard deviation within them so we had
to cover standard deviation also some
people do actually chart up standard
deviations so that's what we will indeed
be doing in the next video
so anyways hopefully that was useful for
some of you guys as always thanks for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time